it's Thursday June [ __ ] second
[ __ ] greetings from podcast Ville the
church is brought to you by my old
American Standard on it supplements
alpha brain shrimp Tec shrimp at a meal
shrimp export this is the way to go if
you're looking after your health on the
way I go to Hana calm promo code Church
you see something you like in the
supplements I can't do nothing awaits
but as far as supplements are concerned
I'll get you 10% off delivered to your
[ __ ] door that's how we roll
you understand me on it the smartest way
to go for your health also this week the
church is brought to you by my bookie
listen you got baseball you got NHL
playoffs you got em ma you got UFC you
got Bellator coming in June you play you
win you get paid whether you've been on
the underdogs the over dogs and my
bookie is the place for you
my bookie loves baseball constantly
delivers great selections of bets for
every game we love hockey we love MMA
and even better the process or your
payout request within 48 hours so you
get paid fast when you win best of all
is their easy-to-use mobile sites and to
make sure you have plenty of cash my
bookie will give you a 50% bonus that's
right 50% bonus on your first deposit
visit my bookie AG today and use promo
code Church that's the way to make it
happen you understand me the church is
also brought to you by like I told you
Mother's Day is around the corner don't
forget to thank the real pros in your
life this year because it's your mom
it's coming up on may 2nd do not forget
write it down right now where would you
be without your mom ProFlowers is here
to help you show your appreciation this
year listen as far as my wife's
concerned she gets the goods 22 of these
dozens so ProFlowers helps you choose
from a variety of bouquets but listen
right now got a dozen assorted roses for
$19.99 that's right
$19.99
double the roses and get a premium vies
for $9.99 more visit bro flowers calm
click the microphone in the upper
right-hand corner and the promo code
happening H ap PE ni ng that's
proflowers.com with the use promo code
happening Mother's Day is May 12 so
don't wait or like a pro and get this
tremendous deal to thank all the moms in
your life are you ready to get this
podcast started is my brother
[ __ ] George Perez the Christ
killer and uncle Joey take this [ __ ]
meal Cisco what's up George Perez you
bad [ __ ] tell him I've only got
to listen to your mama's house you
taught that [ __ ] up our dog it
was awesome a man might stream America
ain't ready for this good now you went
in there [ __ ] them up I went in there
was talking [ __ ] yeah I seen it and it
is tremendous I'm so proud of you what's
happening baby thank you you know baby
just [ __ ] following orders and
shooting out commands dog that's it you
know it's the same [ __ ] grill every
goddamn time man
yeah never real realize that that it's
repetitive but you enjoyed so much that
you don't mind it's yeah putting the
[ __ ] screw on a low more in the
factory you're in a line work one line
workers we have to do the same [ __ ]
every day same military I was [ __ ]
some innate there's something with 10
this number 12 and if not you just once
you lose that passion the [ __ ] stops
rolling I feel you like I still turn
down [ __ ] you do yeah like nah I gotta
go do a show baby I can't I can't I
gotta do a show I turned it when did you
turn down [ __ ] never I have no choice
Hank you lookin I gotta take it while
it's dead you don't say you're missing a
leg I got a dive in [ __ ] it I know what
you say no no the sacrifice is big yeah
I'm trying to become something whether
it's a plumber sacrifice is big you get
all these outside sources trying to hey
and listen don't get me wrong dawg you
fall apart from time to time and
obviously today they have yeah ain't
nothing wrong with that we've done 21
straight nobly yeah I don't talk [ __ ]
but I rest as much as I play I got you
yeah yeah I'm apparently and I'm sending
emails but you know what there comes a
time where they want to sit down watch
the news oh I feel you
and I watch world loose tonight I watch
something on Telemundo you know every
day when you go home you don't comedy
you need that hour - [ __ ] yes I lay on
one I give thanks every day and I've
told my wife this I go we don't live in
a house we're in the rush of the morning
you want a PES Neela be in a rush in the
morning or our [ __ ] that rised me crazy
and I know you didn't grow up and know
an ugly Hills near did I know diddly
well we grew up a little quieter a
little bit more structure but what I'm
trying to say is there's nothing like
when you got a [ __ ] and there's
something in the bathroom doing that
[ __ ] hat yeah and then you go in
there and stink it up and you [ __ ] it up
for the rest of the family yeah but
that's what happens because of having
one bathroom I don't like living in that
rush I grew up in that rush with people
that in the morning were taking this and
then yeah I think they go to the car and
it running because they forgot the keys
that [ __ ] just gets you like damn then
you're running late then you got to walk
up a hill like you're in a bad home it
just unsettling and that's why I always
knew that I was not gonna have a day job
yeah I had day jobs but just because I
had kids you know I mean like those
bandits were little I always knew I was
I have a job yeah I knew I wasn't gonna
do in the daytime I got you not know
nine-to-five know I always did not like
that rush I didn't know what it was till
about few years ago but I I knew at the
age at 16 I knew I didn't want to danger
I wanted to work in a warehouse at night
or bartend hey Lia we should have yeah
yeah I wanted my days to myself I always
thought that staying out of a bar is a
good thing
okay I rather stay the [ __ ] out of a bar
and stay out of a social circle and have
my daytime I could get up like work till
5:00 go home everybody's getting ready
and leave you put a cheese omelet on
yeah you watch cartoons you smoke a
joint you gonna come on and people go to
bed around 8:00 in the morning they're
up at 2:00 mm-hmm you know they're up at
2:00 they get up they see what's going
on yeah some days you take
go to sleep though for but some days you
get up you [ __ ] do [ __ ] you work out
you very nothing to be at work till 9:00
yeah you get to [ __ ] all the girls that
get their late lunch break yeah I'm
saying maybe yeah cook in the daytime
you help your wife so when she comes
home with five years I've always i'ma
being a kid and looking at wanna hasn't
gone day job what was your first job dog
like honest like where you had to give
your ID and your social the jobs I had
grown up a part of who I am today
you know okay because the people I work
for you couldn't cut corners you either
did the work or you did and you did it
that way
yeah not your way we don't give a little
we don't care what you want to do and
they would tell you your way is wrong
it's wrong they were right because
always looking for a way out when you're
young you're looking at the clock yeah
you don't really want to work one of my
first jobs is a hot carrier like I'd
worked with my mother although she by
Sheree is what when you make cement you
have to bring it out late Mason's our
guys you have to work in front of that
you can't work behind that which means
you have to have if they go for a brick
they don't have a brick that's money
yeah so that Rick's gotta be laid I know
what you mean I just how they go to grab
yes this cement has to be wet yeah they
let the so you have to watch 18 things
at once you have to keep making cement
keep it in the machines yeah it's like a
tender now for what you and for
bricklayers
put it in the [ __ ] on the thing it's
a wooden board put it there [ __ ]
bucket yeah so it's wet put water on it
yeah oh [ __ ] they're light on brick and
make sure the scaffolds done yes well
they get that yeah you gotta send them
they have you have to have the moved on
there's a great educator of me that was
a very great educator me because it
taught you to look beyond what you're
doing in front of you just just enough
to make your job easier you know when
you paint if I hire some kid on the
street the pains gonna come in here they
just gonna throw paint on the walls
gonna paint the hinges
everybody knows that paint 90% of his
preparation yep
it's taping the edges taping the windows
yeah it takes ten minutes
but the jobs gonna be that much better
take the sockets off the [ __ ] war it
is all huh sockets not grave because he
took it off the wall when he painted it
all those little things I pay you for
life to not to cut ends like huh okay
the first job I really had that I had to
be like on my own like the brick
masonite work or I knew but my mother
died my friend came to me he goes I had
a better job I want you to take my job
and I'll never forget I went down there
gave they got my ID did the thing if the
guy goes I'm gonna give you a test today
I want you to sweep the room I knew from
my stepfather cuz I used to get
aggravated with my stuff on my cell
phone goes you're not sleeping right
yeah like a [ __ ] when I tell you to
sweep the garage you got to move
everything yeah sweeping then put it
back then move the other side sweep that
then put it back then put it all in the
middle then sweep it all out towards the
front straight up so that's what I did I
moved the feelingly when he came back he
goes you know what you're doing look how
confused I didn't work manual labor I
didn't do that but I worked a lot of
minimum-wage jobs like CBS movie caddie
I did I working since 1400 [ __ ] I never
I bought my first car I I grew up it's
different I was very lucky I grew up in
a very white very nice part of town but
everyone I grew up with my parents
bought them BMWs all that I bought my
first car I didn't my parent I was the
poorer family in the nice town so I've
worked since I was 14
you guys still had Honda's and [ __ ] yeah
I had a 97 Chevy Cavalier that the the
brakes didn't work the door and it would
got really cold the door wouldn't close
like the door just open at the stop
signs I'm the worst car it's a piece of
[ __ ]
I loved it though well Fred shoulder was
different my first car was like an 87
Monte Carlo and my Georgie's mom my
oldest son Georgie her uncle they all
were mechanics rebuilding lowrider
so I had a primer Joey all it had luxury
edition headlights you know I was a
cholo back then it was all did you call
bounce no I was I was wrong no I only
had it for like eight months because the
fuel exhaust was too [ __ ] up and I
didn't really know about that [ __ ] and
my girl was like I'm getting a [ __ ]
headache sitting in this car my comedy
car had these dogs yeah I had a pat pull
over and take a nap every hour on the
hour
I'd rather suicide note I was like Brody
[ __ ] up I had to drive one night from
northern Oregon to Seattle was a 4-hour
Drive in that it took me nine hours oh
that was a terror it's the reason why I
Drive a Subaru toy is because it's the
best car I could drive for the money
mm-hmm number two it's safe to write
it's real safe
it's I know what I do to cars I got you
what I did the cars from 1979 to 1990
was just absurd not even putting oil and
I give it a fine no I took care of them
because I paid for the cars huh but the
dents
oh okay the crashes yeah that the blown
up [ __ ] thing that spins timing belt
timing belt yeah I blew up cause you
know 20/20 did I remember there's gotta
be another ten I'm getting in cars with
you all the time I had the worst luck
with cars I had a car light on fire
bites yeah one of my cars that on fire
service call right both the engine blew
you know another time I had a van I got
caught an electrical wire only that
could happen to an idiot like me you
know when it snows in New Jersey you
moved attraction and I wanted to make a
u-turn on the hill oh and the [ __ ]
bumper of the car got caught and the
electrical wires the reason why I'm
still alive is through the grace ago and
you know me with the radio blasters
trying to pull
the ties and fires coming and dog I went
on I'm like holy [ __ ] I thank God the
street kids coming by at like 4 bucks in
my pocket and they helped me take it out
pull the van back and undo that that van
I think blew up so the only people I
work for gave me cars and their cars
were great
you just go out there like a ho my foot
is the size thirteen of heavy you know I
forget I work for a car dealer I work
for two car dealerships back-to-back
that I'd equip because that'd blow up
their cars no way just was driving them
home
there was a used-car lot that I took the
car to Wyoming I worked for these people
just for the car yes so you just work
and get the hustle to take the car they
love me because I speak Spanish sell
cars and I told him for me to work I
gotta get a caller to just drive to work
back and forth ain't taking no bust and
they were cooled first car they gave me
had this old problem they gave me like
four cars in two months in the last car
I took the wyoming on the way back that
was smoking I barely made it to work
Monday oh my god I like to feel like the
leader was on fire
yeah and when I got that touch the hood
in my hand almost burned it was 20 below
zero so that's what saved the car and I
pulled up and I just left it there and I
said I walked away no guys I got that
big comedy break they're like what are
you talking about HBO called in fact I'm
on a plane right now good luck thank you
Emily use your reference I thank you
ma'am
where's the keynote then you fill it up
yeah like 20 minutes later my page it
was going off come back what you doing
in this [ __ ] car so I was blog then I
went to work I GP go plays imagine what
they went to go touch the hood dog go I
want to work at a GPU a place they put
me in a brand new [ __ ] car I went
again to do comedy up in Vail or
something one night I had to sleep on
the side of the street cheat and put you
up pulled over the side of the road put
the heat on college clubs didn't give
like features that wasn't a comedy club
was a one-nighter up house okay they
they gave the feature and
lion I took the key they told me when I
took the gig but ya took it just to be a
hardhead yeah the gig just to work and
and I'll never forget starting a car in
the morning and tan it was like 10 below
and I started to calm the whole warming
and I was a little late for work mostly
yeah
and the [ __ ] the [ __ ] whatever
that oh you're talking the serpentine
belt not that big one that goes I go
yeah it's that oh yeah Walden was
running late and I made up a story and I
just finally go listen I quit you're
causing van [ __ ] is it doing I mean I
just had horrible left when I get the
mold I didn't have a call to Delhi zone
the delish the hog food place let me
have delivery car they were so kind they
would close the shop at 8:00 I would
come in a quarter after 8:00 and they go
we don't want to leave the car out take
it and I will go do comedy with a car I
think that's how fortunate hell yeah I
would run the different places the last
one I drove that call the lights blew up
done that what an accurate I thought I
was Johnny Bananas and one of that that
car still laying somewhere on some signs
of the [ __ ] I was going to add ever
nugget
I had to go the wolf Mike Castle give me
dealership so I could steal a car from
the lot bring it to my house take the
rims off and the tires putting on Mike
on and sweet we are back with the [ __ ]
up rims yeah
guys I've done it all oh wow oh gee
crying I mean before I bought a [ __ ]
what was Toyota Nissan Sentra
it was no way the Toyota Celica what was
it before was Nissan Datsun
that's he's a Datsun b210 yeah that
[ __ ] was tough is now that was
my first real comedy road car it was
reliable that car got me from cop I
bought it with 150,000 miles whoa the
car was bent that cop gave me another
hundred thousand for a year and
hard that car with me was the frame
broke in Alaska that was it and then
finally in Seattle I crashed into a car
but I was driving to the contest I was
going up hill and there was a dude I
rear-ended him he came out bride just
bought this car he had just bought he
had just drove off the luck
oh we exchanged numbers never heard from
this again did you get in the real
number yes I gave the real VIN now my
insurance I told my shirt I made up some
insurance information oh sure it's no
registration no no I've gone through
cars
I know what you mean the auto for me
like when people bust my balls like gyro
you need a Cadillac for what yeah I
already had a big car look at the right
side straight up dance up in the front
then [ __ ] he said your abs my sound I
Drive by sound I got more [ __ ] dents
in my car and what's-his-name got in his
head and I just say no more I don't see
I don't see the once you learn the real
Vallot listen you're just gonna mess it
up first - I don't buy cars I Lisa ok
once my credit got good back to good I
study some cars why what's your theory
behind that you lease what depreciates
and you owned what appreciate I got you
know it's a value no much of a hard car
is it loses like a thousand when you
leave in LA right soon as you leave the
lawn that long in that seventeen
eighteen hundred it's just a beat-up
thing that's why I've always told people
if you have the means and the credit
lease because you're renting the car ok
first of all if you go buy a car go over
then tell them I want to put five
thousand then get that car they'll come
back to you still with a 450 480 payment
you're just throwing away money and got
money after if you take that five
thousand and take four thousand and put
in the CD and take that thousand need to
lease a car and get your payment it's
Lisa
it's less buying a month to lease don't
wanna lose to own when you rent it when
you own a car you don't really own it
Chieko
yeah for five years the bank's got that
title yeah your brother will do whatever
you see them exact
in my point mm-hmm Abe Lincoln said you
lease what depreciates and you own what
appreciates what appreciates a house
real estate ok stocks bonds that always
a car just goes backwards from the time
you buy unless you have a Toyota or
Subaru and Colorado once the slow T
touches the ground your car goes up in
value at the house then how does the
Subarus yeah it all depends in the
summer you could steal a Subaru in June
you could steal the soup for sticker
price there's an H snow okay you go
ahead you go and just tell the guy if I
don't see the stick I ain't buying
come come out and show you make a
hundred can we make a little problem
maybe 100 over sticker finance the car
somebody else you don't make no money on
the financing but when you hold a car
you don't really own it so now you're
paying five years for the [ __ ] car
and love it once you buy the car now you
own the car that's $75,000 hundred
thousand miles and you put two dents on
it now you own that car now what are
your comes into you're ready I get sick
of driving the car every three years you
just pass it on and the first time and
what you do is you go with a car family
that's good to you so you keep renting
the same car yeah and you go between two
or three different models Subaru has
three different four different models I
just got a different model every three
years and try enough and they don't trip
on like the the beings and all that show
more [ __ ] down payment and I'm the one
from the last car carries over oh [ __ ]
who carry your keys and if you're smart
enough the payment only goes up five
house okay five to ten dollars damn you
could do that every three years I do
different [ __ ] I go to those you know
those auction things and I bring my
homie that's a mechanic nothing wrong
with that yeah in the room and we go
when does they let you take a look at
the car you just can't sit in it but you
can look at it and he's just like all
right on me I already know that one like
the one I have outside I got that for
600 2010 Nissan Altima damn and then I
put 3,000 and a new engine a new
everything and now that cars gonna last
me 12 years 10 years I do want that
content [ __ ] years now I I just gave
it to my kids everything
years they get the car like I just keep
going down every three years it's a
smart thing when you have kids I don't
believe kids should get a car right off
the bat no like I should have never
gotten oak off the bat a lot of people
should you should give a kid a four
hundred car let them dent it [ __ ] put
rotten apples in there yeah just
something that was like where I came
from the neighborhood I came from there
was no driving nice cars that always
gets attention I'm not a drug dealer
yeah and I still don't want the
attention well my neighborhood were
cholo so it was like fix up an old car
and make it look good which is also a
[ __ ] crazy you like I had friends
that would buy like a Mustang okay in
Jersey that I have lowriders huh
and you're now address yeah there was a
trip you know unless is something
colorful or something like that but we
weren't big into that like okay the kids
I grew up a warrant into cause it's a
California killing us well the weather
out there destroys cars - yeah so the
cars get rusty you know all that [ __ ]
right that's big if a car has rust that
panel is pretty much done you could
spray paint and put and rust-oleum and
finish it up it'll kill time yeah a time
but watch Russ gets into that metal you
have to keep buffing it down it's like
psoriasis and [ __ ] yeah you know what I
miss about cars is [ __ ] in cars I
used to [ __ ] a lot and from like 16 to
23 in a car cuz I always had a baby's
mom so I wasn't spending money on a
hotel back then it was seatbelt rash and
a lot of ass you [ __ ] a lot of cars I
got my dick sucked [ __ ] in cars right
in the front seat you know but no I
wasn't privy ain't the [ __ ] in the car
that's disgusting they walked by yes
sometimes you got to close them in the
car just to close it yeah and you got
them on the way homeless suck my dick a
little bit let me eat your [ __ ] just to
make sure there's no misunderstandings
if they say no and whatever I mean yeah
I had five brothers dog it was harder
being grown they would try to take a
machete I gotta I we got beer you know
my brothers were scandalous you still
get along
who has a crazy question uh one of my
brothers doing life in prison I really
want to talk to him
fucked-up crime I can't accept now I
only talked to two of my brothers
broadly I mean I talked to him but not
really and [ __ ] they're more they're
very different from me say mom same dad
yeah yeah a month my dad had five wives
but he only staying with my mom
cuz she gave him six sons and my dad
didn't have boys with any of these other
wives and we're all at your apart except
for me I was born [ __ ] her tubes tied
and I still made it dog and I have a
little brother my dad got some strong
ass nut and it's [ __ ] it's wild like
I feel ashamed sometime because I don't
even know my brother's birthday to this
day I don't know some of their birthdays
did you drift apart no my dad made us
real competitive when we were little so
it was always trying to be competitive
from it he didn't make us but it was
just like that we wanted to have his
pride his honor you know what I mean so
all my brothers were competing in sports
and athletes and I was the little I was
five I was four years apart from
everybody's your partners cuz my mom had
her tubes tied so she did have another
kid for four years and it was just real
my dad was like a cartel Mexican
American bad [ __ ] never said I
loved you barely at the house but he
showed up when it was a rent was doing
all that [ __ ] you know he was like he
was a co your thick Joey he had one job
for child support in the daytime and at
night he would work to support us and
then he would just take off on the
weekends and come back lay cars and [ __ ]
in yeah how many kids did he have the
rumors like 13 15 total from five
different wives is your dad still with
us
nah nah Pop's is gone all right B what
is it require to be a [ __ ] coyote
that's just dog back at this is like 85
Joey and my dad was smooth cuz you know
he was smooth dog like
he had homies you know he had friends
everywhere and one of his buddies was
the meet on the border patrol but not
the one you drive through the one you
walked through so my dad would get fake
IDs made in Orange County and since he
had six kids he would tell me to get six
outfits from all a go-getter alpha from
all your brothers we drive the TJ he'd
feed them we'd all stay in a hotel room
for like four hours
get everybody like hey look you put so
they would come home and clothes from
America you know I mean when you're
wearing nobody had pull my back in the
80s and TJ or Nike or guess and then my
dad would use all of our kids birth
certificates just so it looks on the
camera that we were showing it then we
would just walk through his car was
parked in the American side we jump in
the car and drop everybody off where
they had to go
what would they pay you dead he was
getting like seven eight thousand ahead
no [ __ ] and because look at it there's
no walk you're not gonna get hurt you're
getting dropped off at your family's
house and my dad he already had like he
in 1994 my dad brought four houses
that's how good he was going buying
houses dawg
that's a lot of [ __ ] a lot and we were
making Luke one time my mom got locked
out we went together that [ __ ] was crazy
we all went and then like they pulled
over my mom's car and she did like three
days but my dad went in there dropped
500 5000 later it was wild dog I've been
to TJ so I know so many like a little
back routes I know they're not there no
more and this is a time where the
cartels didn't give a [ __ ] about human
trafficking to them back then it was all
weak coke and speed you make a winded
human trafficking take like such a big
thing that the cartels didn't care about
him now they do the yeah yeah because
now a human is better than a drug
because if a drug doesn't make it a drug
gets took if a human doesn't make it he
come
right back and it's another 10,000 now
it's 12 15,000 for one person and you
don't even get it like my dad you have
to walk it chance getting [ __ ] caught
all that [ __ ] it's very different they
had a good system back then you know you
look at it from the other perspective
man you come from a place where just you
have nothing you know and your family
pays for you yeah I mean I know what the
Chinese is should they bring them over
in working working massage parlors you
really do bills tab is paid
there's the massage parlor next to the
strip club I work at and oh but all the
massage girls there got nice hands cars
and I was thinking like what is this is
legit one is on a certain I think it
late they let him keep the money I don't
know yeah it's real Asian like even with
the ice autocue memory about it like the
Coyotes they'll take them to like a
house once they get to America huh and
if they don't have the money they kind
of keep them there yeah locked up until
someone pays yeah we got a job of their
friends Mexican restaurant is a busboy
at 3:35 an outpost tips until they pay
off the $10,000 yeah but that's not
really that's like some mostly it's like
a we need everything cuz it's it's there
now you know I'm saying it's like you
know this is the new [ __ ] that I'm
hearing and I don't know if it's
accurate but like one of my home he says
that little kids now are like [ __ ] it
we'll take the cocaine we'll jump over
with it and that'll be payment to get my
dad over there then he'll come get me
like [ __ ] kids are sacrificing
now and just taking drugs over to get
the money they could bring their parents
that crazy dog just to show you what the
value of America is straight uh you know
just to show you what you know a couple
months ago Trump made a [ __ ] joke or
whatever he said like crack me up he's
like you know what he'll take up all the
[ __ ] refugees won't put him in
sanctuary cities I see how much you like
it
that was finding which means here
just go low see I mean I'm not
politically woke as they say uh well
then what the [ __ ] he's trying to do and
at first I got a little mad George I'll
tell you why cuz I'm Spanish uh-huh and
it bothers me that he just focuses on
the wall yeah we're at a point in our
country when we have to focus on all of
immigration I mean there's too many of
all of us here never right now and then
I was like whoa to [ __ ] mine and make
that decision you know what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am I have to
say that close it all off you know what
America is a dream and a half of some
people and you know what we as Americans
are [ __ ] lazy and we forget we forget
when we look at a [ __ ] immigrant well
Dale do ya when you're going you know
Guzman was on Rogan and he was like who
the [ __ ] cleans your hotel rooms
who the [ __ ] does all these shitty jobs
immigrants and it's not shitty jobs this
is jobs that Americans have made shitty
because all of a sudden we got too much
pride to be a [ __ ] grass cutter or
you know there's gotta be white kids
that grew up and go I want to be a
carpenter but the first thing you know
here is it's tough because how you don't
learn to be a carpenter
they got Mexicans working for you but
somehow hole work circles work yeah how
to be a carpenter so now when you want a
job so I mean the growth has definitely
yeah it's a no I've become a carpenter
you gotta be a carpenter's helper first
rate uh
you're gonna get an eighteen-year-old
not a [ __ ] college now I want to get
splinters in my hands all day for eight
bucks don't listen for eight bucks an
hour you see this Mexican kid he don't
even say boots laughing you know white
people my god we we're doing it in
fasting really skinny little Mexican
yoke disease and fasting all these on a
lifelong fast and I want to hire you
frame our to do what
tell me stupid stories are you gonna go
to Coachella yeah you say let's go to
Coachella Zach you know so we forget me
I've never forgotten that [ __ ] but
before I think about doing stupid [ __ ] I
think about like what the [ __ ] is an
immigrant doing right now
well having heard about what's happening
on the
Farms is like crops are going bad on the
farmers because they rigid all these
raids and they took all these illegal
immigrants out and they literally can't
find enough people to work on the farms
so we have but it is it's so funny my
wife and I were having this conversation
how they have removed the were that
worth work ethic from kids you don't go
until McDonald's no more say a lot of
young kids well I remember that you're
right I went to a lot of places you know
I hate that they have removed the paper
out I hate that there's no more yeah a
paper route I did [ __ ] yeah I didn't
have a bike I said put that [ __ ] on my
shoulders I delivered on the bike walk
sweet slow
I still bring in the papers dumped on
the corner you had a gotta get them
before they melted yeah what oh you went
there challenge I don't I was on the
East Coast and I decided to take that
route January first like I just wanted
the paper route did you have to deliver
in that when it's no - and all that
paper route in the afternoons I took a
paper out January first like I said I
thought I could do this [ __ ] first off I
don't walk 10 blocks just to get there
and my newspapers would be on the corner
and I have that little laundry cart and
I have to deflate them the string you
gotta bring a knife and hunt them off
and then [ __ ] take the plastic rats
to grab and then play ball put them in
the plastic wrap and put them in the
thing yeah you had a ring with all the
people's names and whether they just got
paper 7 days a week or they just got
Sunday only okay if they only got Sunday
a table Solomon the guy would give you
another 50 cents and then you worked on
your tips I did that [ __ ] for maybe a
year I want all the awards and then like
my mom is like what are you doing I'll
pay you more you know watch TV and
[ __ ] just stop the bar and clean but
work ethic and I tell you what happens
like what that work ethic is one thing
but going to work for yourself
like will you do it you're in a
corporation straight up I've been a
corporation since nineteen in 1987
I decide I was a corporation when I
heard the words that you can work for a
fixed income or your life could be a
there's no ceiling on your salary
and dog I became a corporation after
that when I was stealing I became a cop
all that [ __ ] I knew at the end of the
month there was a magic number there's a
I knew that there was three numbers
there was a number that'll keep me alive
there was a number that I could do a
little something with yeah it was
nothing like the snort some coke and
have a few [ __ ] drinks and Coco's and
watch TV but there was three numbers and
you might either had to hit one of those
numbers god forbid you surprised the top
number then you would live top of the
[ __ ] you want to live but there was
always numbers that I had a hit you know
I didn't want to work for the
conventional salary I never did like
since I was in [ __ ] high school I was
like I get it now I don't want to have a
ceiling on my income oh I didn't come
over my a ceiling on my income mm-hmm
you know that's why I always loved sales
I adored sales
yeah it's longer yeah bonuses bro
straight up so if I sell thirteen I get
five if I so 14 I get another five
hundred fifteen years a thousand a
thousand per car after that watch me
yeah tell a [ __ ] like me if you
go sell three cars you get a hundred
hours cash today watch me watch if I
make calls or watch if I call my
girlfriend I'll watch it I will go up to
people give them like a five minute spit
pitch and if they weren't [ __ ] buying
get the [ __ ] out I want to come look at
cars go to the mall down the corner I
got all the cars in the world just walk
around the light of the mall the more
those [ __ ] clock counterclockwise you
can walk along and they just look at you
like what yeah yeah either will bono
with done what do you want yeah I could
end your day right now you can be home
in two hours are you gonna talk to all
the car the car you're looking for is
right here the price don't work for you
will make the work it'll come close to
you I always love that type of [ __ ] I
always love talking you know how did
mind hard-working
I don't mind digging the trench choice I
did that for seven years I was a cement
man I was a certified journeyman like I
can form it and finish it what the
concrete I can still do that [ __ ] no
shell yet they sent me I was an
apprentice they sent me to this Academy
at the
Whittier Sheriff's Department me and all
kinds of other 19 or 23 year old people
learning like how to I used to have a
eight pound sledge hammer [ __ ] metal
stakes I'll smooth over you house
2019-20 because I just had Georgie
before that I used to do telemarketing
like hi you said I was good at booking
timeshare appointments and then I was
like [ __ ] this my girlfriend's uncle is
like a homie you need to take care of
your son you want to work they gave me a
job John Palacio gave me this job at
Terra Cal in Irwindale I'll never forget
that [ __ ] like our first job was in
Agoura Hills he said be there at 6:30 I
was there at 5:15 chillin coffee
doughnuts
stinking construction was give you a
boots they're like throw that [ __ ] away
John let's go hey dog
I worked my [ __ ] ass these fools were
animals animals and they taught me that
was like my first adolescence dog like
that was when I learned how to eat
Ashley that was like they all these old
men would [ __ ] with me
and they're like oh you're 20 you have
an apartment that when you go home put
her underwear on your head and [ __ ]
sniff it and boner I was doing this
stupid [ __ ] my girl for go what the [ __ ]
is wrong oh yeah hey you know what that
job I love joy because like you said
you're working with 13 other men no one
there's a snitch everybody has their own
bad habit of something he smokes he does
weed that fool does uppers downers coke
alcoholics it was it was dope and that's
how we get to make fun of each other and
[ __ ] find out who's who sucks and who
doesn't you know it's so weird how you
look at kids and your own kids you know
like what is good for them when they get
out of high school yeah I'm going
through that in the back of your mind
you like you know why you need to go to
college see like wait a second bro no
I'm from the school of hard knocks and I
learn just as much as in college by
doing this job this job in this job I
did this job for three years this job
for a year in this job for you
and it made me help to everything I had
to be hip to prepare me for life you
know yeah I'll have said it before on
this podcast sales because you're always
gonna be selling yourself the rest of
your life you only need your 65 and you
calling [ __ ] Social Security you're
gonna be selling yourself I'm missing an
eye
[Laughter]
yeah and you have that joy you got this
charisma this likability and it's like
newness Joey always says like a new word
like what the [ __ ] would you come up
with that I can see I can see you as a
salesmen just out there come on I loved
it I know you want don't you want to
meet a girl get this call I love the
artists selling right I loved the are
there selling especially not selling to
be a jerk-off but to sell you because
you definitely need this particular
product okay like that's why now if I
ever quit doing comedy you're podcasting
I'd sell Subarus fa20 is yeah you sell a
Subaru I can sell this [ __ ] out of a
Subaru if it's something that you love
you know we get I get things responses
all the time you know it's so weird in
the beginning we would take whatever it
was chocolate-covered strawberries
whatever now I look to see if the
product if I would use the product okay
you know if I had a company that [ __ ]
uh you know I needed to get to spray you
know quit quick makes a great portable
toothbrush you know and has a timer III
appreciate yeah a timer for each side
you know [ __ ] manscaped you know he's
a trimmer and they have all this stuff
for your balls
I wish she they sent me the razor the
manscape and all the stuff they got like
a different color from your ball hairs
to your face hair just got a bunch of
different thing of all this not to you
shave your balls with some I don't want
it close to my own I'm gonna shave and
trim under here under these little nose
hairs to improve people listen I got a
show we do that there's no phone prison
dollar yes give our ballsy but I go
ahead shave your hand yeah yeah
you know I mean and and then crash you
have stuff to trim here oh wow goateed i
need something like that right no
manscape this [ __ ] they landscape all
wipe eyeball wipe ball wiping you wipe
your balls I keep it in my little
jiu-jitsu badass movie after you don't
be walking around was down you know when
the Lord you left throw [ __ ] my boss
different you never you never prepared
for a good boss haha you notice that
whatever somebody was so true they smell
like the death of Billy Goats right you
bring your living room dry when you come
out of shower you just did Irish Spring
and you're sitting there watching the
NFL in your legs open like your balls
dry this [ __ ] them no ball sniff is
flying through the window they wanna
suck your [ __ ] you bump into [ __ ]
yeah when I was young I'm not talking
about the last 19 years whatever I
wanted they got a dick sucking my dick
always smell
nobody won at least girls always said
you hold on I have to go to the bathroom
first cuz they check gonna see what
their [ __ ] onion smells like to make
sure they throw some hot water on it we
don't do that we just give you dick
without the washing the [ __ ] that
little white stuff buying you dick don't
get that you know don't pull the skin
back for a week it looks like a Mexican
chin I was a kid dawg I hated watching
my dick it wasn't necessary the grade
that you know you gotta wash your dick
when you young you like I don't meet the
watch this thing think about that one
day you pull the skin back looks like a
girl told a yeah looks like q-tips that
died yes so who the [ __ ] means that
their life so I just do the best you can
they have the ball why manscape just a
good product owner I could I could sell
what I believe it yeah it sounds like it
on it I could sell if I believe it I
went to honor headquarters where rogen
dog was dog it was [ __ ] crazy lead
Aubrey yeah
Aubrey was awesome he came to the show
the first night and then we went out I
was scared I haven't worked out in years
and we did stations and [ __ ] but they
have like a jiu-jitsu class for adults
one for kids they got this like Hugh
place where they have like the drinks in
them what are the supplements and all
dog it was it was awesome and they have
station yeah station do club bad I did
the role the bars or was that shaking
the dumbbells kettlebells kettlebells
some jump rope and then the punching bag
and it was weird dog cuz like I've
always been the guy at the gym that's
like these [ __ ] were animals no
there was girls there squatting like
three plates but it was it was bad I
like the vibe that they had there I'll
tell you some always done a great job
yeah great guy you know I could talk
[ __ ] I mean they were a sponsor like
three months in and I liked what they
were doing already I like the Alpha
brain you know yeah I didn't know much
about the shroom techno stuff but the
more I work with them the more I read
their website oh I can't repeat the
words that you read on their website
they're for smart people but from taking
their products I know it's a good
product
yeah like you know it's a good [ __ ]
product I gotta order some more I
haven't ordered you know they give me an
amount every month okay
I get a little bit a couple I don't go
crazy I don't take advantage of them I
just get it - I'm a crazy one and every
other month I'll get the [ __ ] alpha
brain and they say you know I've called
Joe and they've sent me kettlebells I
haven't and they they sent me the club
bats Wow guess I couldn't you go work
out so I just did the club bat I hit the
bag in my backyard that's a son I got
I'm on the antibiotics still so I gotta
be [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] so it was just
uh it's a real good company and that
that's basically it is selling what you
like I could never sell a [ __ ] what's
those things you sell on the phone no
time for attention [ __ ] anybody
that's enough time sure they get raped
now finally I've seen the commercials
and you call the service nay I'll rape
you with a Timeship yeah
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] together timeshare
from David okay we're gonna come out
here every year once you you no you're
not no you're not you only get sick of
that for [ __ ] years now well we rent
with smart it's not smart this mind your
business
yeah I don't want to go anywhere the
same [ __ ] day yeah I don't want to go
anywhere twice the same bottom year I do
it in comedy clubs get furious at me I
know you're not come on they're trying
to add shows when you hear that you're
like about my plane leaves tomorrow my
plane leaves tomorrow I had three days
you got me that's it yeah me for the
best you went to a six a.m. show I'm all
in I'm awake I'm ready to [ __ ] write
but enough it's just uh but what the
timeshare I was an appointment setter so
it was kind of like all I had to do was
get him to go to the appointment and
they would give me 60 bucks and a couple
that's you're like the mayor Walsh with
you the same dinner and welcome into the
cave this is gonna be a great thing they
do the midnight show is [ __ ] just going
there I'll come check on you now and
come back on our dust water aha
gasoline they're looking at you are you
gonna help this up I thought it was a
triple feature yeah I thought it was the
double hat what is it that Dirty Harry
triple feature yeah yeah I can't take
people to the grave like that
I've tried well I tried don't get your
eyes I used to work for a company I used
to sell medical Scioscia okay this scam
was if we don't get the package back in
15 days we'll build it it was $1.99
you're a doctor yeah guess what if I
gotta paint 200 hours or walk to that
post office there's some days if you
catch me at the right moment I'll give
you the 200
and I don't know that [ __ ] post
office you know didn't you used to go to
those timeshare meetings oh well you're
a common goal for the $50 yeah
because I'll give you 75 bucks and they
give you like a free jukebox and like a
vacation pass dog there's nothing like
when you walk into a place you got no
money you got bad credit and you don't
know the first time and you're gonna put
them through hell because like know why
not I got bad credit
oh we work a bad credit people all the
time and that's when you start asking
for [ __ ] really will get you
sandwich just fill out this little
credit app and take your time with the
credit app got any chips
you got any jello honey whipped cream I
didn't like that and by the time you
nice and full they run your credit app
and they come back with their face pay
like listen yeah you were right you
should have bad credit and now it just
gets around so you just keep going these
time Shizen at the end of it you go you
know I got back read yeah I just came to
see what it was all about well thank you
for coming thing they get pissed off for
you yeah but whatever only here for
three days
I gotta take all the $75 pieces I can't
the clothes for five shows in those days
Myrtle Beach pay like 300 bucks
damn I'm gonna pay you know 450 450 a
feature with uh with a condo up around
the corner which is nice to add a nice
oh yeah you could walk to the beach from
the condo so I would turn a 450 week
into a [ __ ] 950 week okay
by doing seminars Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday I slept and then
I stayed there to the next guys came in
on Wednesday uh-huh that's how you saved
my money you just stay that time though
tumble lady when she comes to cleaning
Monday night I ain't gonna cooking or do
nothing
I'm saving money I'm not gonna eat this
[ __ ] dirty time the hell no
supermarket eat sandwiches I got hey I'm
saving on rent for the next week too
yeah if you're on the road and you're
staying on the road you stay in the
condo till Wednesday
it only takes you a day drive to the
next destination don't let you stay in
the condom to save money
oh cool yeah a lot of people would I
said I mean you're above condo work
right now yes oh yeah [ __ ] no more
comment Grogan took you the fourth
season ha that [ __ ] [ __ ] me yeah make
coffee or bra he took me those four
seasons once I think it was in Denver
brother they had a coffee machine in the
hallway like an espresso on the 12th
floor every floor had accomplish years
ago I thought I hit the jackpot I was
worried when I went I lost my [ __ ]
credit card in Houston so I [ __ ]
pulled out 3,000 bucks thinking I was
gonna be like yo here's 3000 bucks does
this cover I went then they're like that
doesn't even cut her cover how much it
costs to stay here I was like I [ __ ] it
so I called my baby's mom said hey I
need you to send your credit card
she's like I got you whatever they were
looking at me weird cuz they didn't know
who I was
once they [ __ ] seen who booked the
room and [ __ ] they came back to the room
[ __ ] they gave me sodas and sandwiches
and [ __ ] like Four Seasons flipped out
they're like hey just so you know you
got $300 credit to eat to watch whatever
you want every day I was like you guys
wouldn't even take my credit card
they're like we made a mistake dawg they
were Britt was wild it was crazy
they took it a faux go to child know we
went to a we ate we with the Alex Jones
on the patio that was wild and nah we
were only there for two days before they
said yeah Friday Saturday came back
Sunday
they wouldn't know that how is Jones
into the comedy club used to happen they
wouldn't live in the story there yeah
I heard Sam was supposed to have them
there on a comedy cast and they're like
nah no [ __ ] yeah you can always edit
this if you want no no I was gonna have
him run the podcast yeah no that's what
I thought was because my producer Xavier
he produces for Sam now okay and he was
like dog a store wouldn't let Alex Jones
on my home be they kicked him out of
7-eleven when I was but what happened
when Isis kicks you out of 7-eleven you
think is somebody of you've really made
the [ __ ] piss I love Alex I love was
cool let me tell you some about ours I
don't know what he's done 70 percent of
this shitty talks about his money and
it's an education for people to listen
uh-huh but the other 30 percent it's so
[ __ ] out there that is a it nullifies
the 70 percent a good [ __ ] like I
watched him on Rogen he was talking on
some [ __ ] that was on the money
mmm-hmm but then he goes off and to
whatever I was gonna have him on about
three or four weeks ago the week before
I went to New York I have to do the
movie and I was sick I was feeling like
[ __ ] and we had done a podcast early and
he called me and he said he's gonna be a
half-hour late
we've been sitting here since 12 o'clock
we just wrapped up a podcast for you to
be here on time early yeah and now
you're gonna be I go what you're gonna
be late to 3:30 like a half on they go
no no he's gonna be there more like 4:30
it's not gonna happen you know I can't
wait him out you in fact your producer
called me like eight times to make sure
we had 3:30 yeah and then Eddie called
and said he had to leave at 4:40 to go
cautious cow
coaches kids softball game I was a
battery yeah the problem was that I
needed Eddie here to play devil's that
like that Devils I forget to calm him
down yeah a lot of calm you know me and
I just know how to yell yeah but if he
comes in here with the craziness I got a
[ __ ] say sup and if he says something
about the school killing with the kids I
gotta throw him off the balcony I got ya
I didn't even know he said any of that
[ __ ] that's so sad I hope you know all
that stuff yeah that's just with the
price hey it's fine I can see you too
just and you know me don't my soul be
talking about kids but now I have a
child I would hate for my child for such
straight up and then somebody mocks my
child strain on this shitty says is
beautiful I love Alex I've had a
hilarious time for hours I had a great
time on the show I gave him edibles
twice
oh he was at the UFC with us twice he
didn't learn his lesson the first time
the first time he came to Vegas and he
called my mother [ __ ] Bluff you know
so uh those edibles don't get me high oh
I don't know what I gave he said that
his body was you know he had some type
of Joe DiMaggio blood like preparation
he wasn't gonna get high me and are in
those days used to come to those things
stuff with animals an acid did you own
Benjamin is this that when it started
and we gave him the real deal we gave
him our Sara piece edible he ate it in
front of us like nothing happened he's
I'm telling you guys you're wasting your
time with this this is not gonna go down
and all somebody got to the USC
and it was the good section of Vegas
this that was one of those places the
MGM Grand
Oh Dispensa Vesey they gave you free
food in this section
till the main card oh wow you don't kind
of get up and nothing ever give you hot
dogs a dyke so i soda pop corn or
pretzel okay and he's either sitting
behind me in front of me and I'm gone me
and I are your job giggling over at the
fights were betting on the fights and
also how his channels is telling us how
these edibles don't work and this shit's
a joke in California just to scan a
consumer and next thing you know bro
that waitress came by and he grabbed
[Laughter]
yeah it comes out of the cemetery ha ha
ha he grabbed his waitress and he's like
excuse me yeah what do you have and
she's saying I got pretzels hot dogs
[Music]
popcorn he goes give me one of each
whoever made this and then after we went
to dinner and he disappeared was your
see in Houston I think it was the GSP
one he came up from Austin and that's
when I had those badass I used to get
these little cookies these little
chocolate chip ha white choco somebody
made them whatever my bra one specific
when he was talking [ __ ] we ate it and
then at the EOC he just yeah and his
assistant came up to me that night now
we don't know where Alex was like an
hour later we were headed out of there
the assistant told rogue yeah your
friend gave me cookies in the hotel
rooms in Washington Joe was mad at me
for like two minutes and we just [ __ ]
died that was the last time I saw that
was the last time I saw him so I was
looking forward to seeing a couple weeks
ago I don't want the church family to
think that I was mean to Donna I don't
really give a [ __ ] if people ban him
yeah it gives us more I like people who
been banned from society yeah I don't
even give you a second chance right uh
it was just that the tie was
constraint is there a conspiracy that he
he used to have the same agent as a
famous comedian that died I don't know
who's the famous cook I forgot it he was
bombed
he's a store favorite not kidding no he
was a young kid that somebody found
Kennison took him under his wing I think
yeah he's from Texas this guy I think he
likes yes Bill Hicks
they said that Bill Hicks is Alex Jones
same age same agents and all that [ __ ]
that's just a Joe he's face right now
like this [ __ ] doesn't like any
of that stuff me neither that's why I
had to tell him he looked at me like
listen it's not that I don't like him no
no you don't like conspiracy theories no
it's nothing like conspiracy theories
it's like anything else how like
anything that wastes a person's time
mm-hmm
I don't like stuff that I look at and go
that's a waste of time
but maybe you look at it and say it's
informative that's great yeah but for
you to really dwell into it and take you
away from your potential
I'm not really into am I meant to
feeding people into I mean I can't they
say I love how I said oh yeah that's
it's not being against some or whatever
you know let's say it's like gay people
we all have a gay friend and we all feel
weird about gay people or whatever but
if you met some like I'm Alina I put the
I put the roster last week from when I
was in a couple weeks like a month ago I
put the roster on the bike in Seattle
Rita Hall was a transgender in 1995 how
many people were really tight with a
transgender guess what I was yeah was
she became a comedian to me okay what
the same well it was a man becoming a
girl yeah well what was Rita's original
name [ __ ] Dumbo he was chat Japanese
and half Irish Wow I was big joking on
stages that he had his dick in a jar no
he didn't yes he so he got it cut off
already
like why the mummified I don't know but
he was on this is though she was on
disability it was a very I saw this
sadness today at the time she really
tried to fit in and I gave her that
opportunity I feel I took a lot of [ __ ]
off yeah I feel on paper I'm a different
person you know I'm saying you know I'll
say some black people you and I both
know how much I love that's come on like
me so you just make a joke you know I
mean but it's when you see the humanity
and I saw them and they read it you know
I know a lot of gay people I'm talking a
lot of gay people and I overcome it
because I had a look at it it's gotta do
with me for me it was hard doc because
getting out of prison we wanted to kill
them
it's always nice yeah yeah and then to
get out I had to like really really
smell off like I dog you're no longer in
a society where the rules those are
rules that you when you go to prison
you're going into another world so
that's the rules of that world will
never join never change right out of the
statement and then when I got out I was
like all right homie now you have an
option and it was kind of weird but a
dog I got a couple homies you know I
mean from comedy comedy makes you meet
you meet weird people I'm weird to them
too you know when you fresh start comedy
yeah the first three or four years three
years you meet open my girls to the
comics and your first daughter is like
wow this isn't a bad job yeah I get to
meet hot chicks I'm gonna try to [ __ ] or
maybe the girl it's the truth I mean it
may be the girl doesn't have the feet on
the floor yeah probably at the time for
comedy you know you're gonna help me
write jokes and all this shame you sleep
with them after three or four years if
you slept with two or three comics then
you start becoming a comic you start
looking at them genderless like last
night saw Felicia what do I gain my
hitting on Felicia yeah what do you gain
by hating on kate quick hitting on Kate
quickly or Chelsea uh-huh good boy
what's next kid more you just get
another comic this is I met George and
he was kind of creepy mmm-hmm you're
gonna see those people for the next one
[ __ ] years yeah and God knows if she
ever marries somebody [ __ ] like a
famous [ __ ] director and she brings
you there I mean you had the
possibilities are endless
yeah we're gonna make you're not in
comedy you're not gonna like everybody
that's the beautiful thing about life
not everybody likes everybody I mean we
we get along and you know what I'm known
about
I don't exactly tons of people are you
go along with but you're not gonna buy
them tea house for Easter Sunday yeah to
eat with you and I understand that the
same thing goes with comedy but well
then 20 years ago I get by 1995 I
understood become a female comic was and
I tried my hardest to be a gentleman
around to true now this goes both ways
see what I mean the female comic she's
at the condo I'm gonna fart I'm gonna
scratch my balls you want you want the
qualms the headliner
so no even if I was featuring that were
headlining I'm gonna induct you into the
family of what it's like to be in this
world yeah
so we're eating lunch if I make a racist
remark would joke you gotta laugh if I
say some of them are farting the [ __ ]
let's check up the ass and put my dick
in the mouth you understand me
yeah as a woman you have to lose those
feelings of ill gross yeah you have to
look at me as another comic yeah it's
really [ __ ] weird what you learn in
the comedy world or even the business
world you know now if you let's say you
get a job at the LA felt first thing you
got to do is take a [ __ ] class now
I'm getting along with co-workers as
well
yeah especially now with Biden touching
that Mexican [ __ ] neck what the [ __ ]
was he thinking you know rubbing her
shoulders and [ __ ] he smoked that
Mexican scout but smelling then dead
[ __ ] cornfield her uncle Fry's corn
all day and he's like what I touch this
Mexican for that's what you get [ __ ]
keep your hands to yourself hugging
these ugly [ __ ] my chickens uglies [ __ ]
that governor she was like a Mexican ate
that job yeah that's like Mexican Planet
of the Apes
why don't we want to [ __ ] the Biden
hasn't had a hard-on since the Nixon
administration he's just so old yeah and
he wanted to fit him well man it's not
allowed no more they call it something
sexual awareness training damn you have
to be sexual to understand
how many than that yeah I've only worked
at strip clubs there's no HR there's no
enjoy a job and that's the thing about
working with that you get to know from
female compas you're like I can't make
this chick my enemy mm-hmm and I can't
[ __ ] her no I'm gonna keep her in
between this and how I yeah she becomes
a now I'm pretty soon if you treat it
with respect
pretty soon you reap what you sow yeah
some day like a little Esther or anybody
they're gonna start dating a writer and
that right is gonna come home when they
say hold it in the end for this part you
don't know you know who's always been
nice to me Joey not the funniest guy in
the world you've been nice to me you
know that's the thing about having those
female friends they look out for you
they have the best like we do the
reverse yeah they have the mother thing
going on yeah you're cool to them that
cool to you you can't [ __ ] every comic
so well i-i've never no no no I never
never I have I've never [ __ ] the
comics really a mistake I'll torture up
well I was I was also seven years into
Connelly and I also have to blame the
blow on that because yeah I just do blow
together and things will happen drugs
just that curl comic yes you know when
you're doing open mic you meet all the
times okay you can either let him come
over your house and sleep it off or you
just start swapping spit with them and
then the [ __ ] them and now you have a
situation at the club oh wow now the
next time she sleeps in the comic you're
gonna be pissed yeah pick up a customer
she's gonna be pissed so it's better
than to get involved unless you're going
marry that yeah unless you look at that
person you know for like three or four
months you and her habit this
electricity it's not working I think
there's somewhere along the lines gonna
bite you in the [ __ ] ass if you get
more funny than she does yeah if she
gets more success than you it never ends
good you know yeah I made the mistake
bro you know we used to leave the comedy
club go to a couple bars then she'd go
what do you wanna do next let's go to
your house you know okay my roommates
out of town
she's a electrician or whatever the [ __ ]
the first couple pay you know when you
first start doing comedy you dedicate
some of your life so much of your life
calmly that's all you're meeting mm-hmm
it's remember that yeah it's not like
you had a chance to meet straight just
when you mean it's great Chiclets comic
you almost had a hobbit for the first
five years of comedy you only meet comic
girls and waitresses yeah you don't meet
nobody outside that circle so then you
go to our library in the chick you're at
those places so I was lucky I was
[ __ ] the strippers that I was working
with all the waitresses at bar which is
also bad business because yeah they're
the ones that report to the Commission
when you can gun you know so you thought
the latest yeah for real if you [ __ ]
wait just another wait just gonna find
out and she's gonna come up behind your
back and the other way to say you know
when Joey Diaz was here Janine suck this
dick of the green well they went
drinking somewhere something like that
so you always blues yeah knock on wood I
did it one time with uh I never really
mess with waitresses my thing was the
other comic and the only other way just
I even looked at was Terry ended up
marrying her Wow
yeah that's what about Terry within the
month yeah I had an idea it was
I just got along with her yeah easygoing
you wanted to be around she understood
me then the second month the third month
she did something that blew my mind like
she didn't care about money she gave me
the last $14 she had four cigarettes to
go to New York you think when the chick
does that you're embarrassed I wasn't
embarrassed like I took it as she were a
team now mm-hmm so right off the bike we
met in July and I knew by August that we
were gonna hang you know this is cool I
don't know if I'll marry it now but
somewhere on the line and look knock on
wood you know yeah things evolved what
else brother it's chilling brother you
know grinding I did my hundred episode
podcast it was [ __ ] insane
they were gonna live we did live at the
strip club at the strip club started in
nine o'clock I got there at 7:30 to set
up we already had 80 [ __ ] in
that place everybody was trying to give
me coke and [ __ ] I was like dog I gotta
perform chill out like it was wild they
kicked the taco grab we're not eating
tonight
there was a taco guy that was outside
that's awful get
Danny every was snorting yeah get out of
here and it was cool
30 strippers showed up I thought about
it I was gonna hit up Li and be like
you're licking ass tonight you down for
the sauce I had a show I would have come
you guys can hang your week any time hey
specially the next couple weeks yeah get
higher get them down and get them feet
some [ __ ] oh I got him - [ __ ] the chick
with chlamydia says get pimples on this
experience
your body will now when he - you want to
become a great command like you want
that you gotta take care of the ropes
and limitations you know why why am i
giving myself chlamydia reptilian
limitations on too many ropes that's a
good limitation it's time for you to
break out of your [ __ ] rusty cage
okay if not you're gonna end up in your
cage forever boy yeah you know what I
got hit up by other other strip clubs
cuz they hurt all the strippers left
their clubs to come to this cuz my
podcast is so much about strippers and
they went back and told the owner it's
Tuesday night this guy had a hundred and
fifteen people in the club at nine
o'clock also joke
as far as strippers or comedians strip
clubs oh I got hit up by the Rhino was
the ride away
there's four of them now they got him in
Torrance everywhere rhinos wouldn't like
they're like The Improv they have one in
Santa Barbara they got one in every
state they ain't [ __ ] around but it's
kind of a cool idea what if I was to do
it I go to a strip club on an off night
take the door have a porn star on stage
of me and a comedian from that state and
you do a live podcast and then
afterwards there's so many customers in
there that the strippers are like all
right now it's time to get naked because
all the strippers at my show were in the
audience that's great and they were just
like hey after the show can we dance in
here and I was like yeah cuz you're
allowed to audition for one day
so they sign a paper they're auditioning
a dog I you ever I just you're gonna
you're gonna come back in a couple of
weeks and I had to sneak away from my
home
[ __ ] party up us it was like 1:00 in
the morning there was still 80 people in
there I was I couldn't find my keys and
they were like I put on my tire like
every winter when you go to the carwash
cuz everybody kept going lose your key
to do coke I was like no you guys are
gonna give him back [ __ ] that so I put
him and I hit him on my car tire and I
was looking for my everywhere and I
finally I found him and I [ __ ] left I
just left
went to the house 20 minutes later were
you at all we're here we want to make
sure you got home safe files I ditched
my cars on the driveway you know I got a
home safe and then the first time I
called into work and about eight years
did you really you were that [ __ ] and
then my owner call me and he was like
don't trip dog no girl showed up today
they were all there last night
yeah see Oh buddy was there a day shift
no because all the day shift came at
work night shift and the club that I did
it at what's called House of Eden in
Fortin my owner of my club his brother
owns that Club I did it like so the
money stayed in the family and guess
what the bar did on a [ __ ] Tuesday
night 7,000 yeah you had all those
people joined Dodger Carlos but there
was bottle buckets of bottles on the
floor like it was too much it was we had
the [ __ ] was there that famous [ __ ]
she showed up and she she's imagine
Patrice O'Neal as a girl [ __ ] she was
wearing a little black leather gloves
off she was with it though she was with
it she was with it was wild uh we gotta
count I'll show you some videos it was a
while it's funny last night I was
talking to Jason Lucas a couple weeks
ago what Evan we were talking about how
people grow
I watched you grow so much in the last
two years
thank you for us been like you just see
people in your life let me keep my eye
on that person and every six months you
keep your eye on three people you watch
their movements you watch this social
media you hear about them you've grown a
lot man thank you brother how you doing
this podcast at this humble treat the
dumb 100 episodes already yeah hundred
and you had more team down there yeah I
had martín Jason rouse I had Danny the
sound engineer from the calm
see though he was keys he's been on my
podcast he was tripping out he was just
like hey George like there's no word SID
I was like Costa nya girls left like
that it was even dog imagine going to a
strip club and usually seen perverts
there
now there was finance they were throwing
money on me onstage it was girls were
telling me to do coke off their [ __ ] in
front of everybody now I was like man if
everybody turns her phone off I'll do it
but I can't do it with phones out you
live in late the motley crew of comedy
that's what I love about you a motley
crew hey man I had to it was fun dog you
know cuz I've always pictured myself a
stripper I always want to get on stage
I hate when new girls come to the club I
hate when [ __ ] dance to my song and I
love strippers dog I got like a special
love yeah cuz they like you know what
now everybody gives me free weed the
poor strippers they're getting robbed so
I work I give all the strippers all the
extra weed that I have and it saves them
an hour because you know they got kids
and families dog they get weed at work
or home smoke smoke with your boyfriend
it's cool I'm getting a nice bond with
strippers I like it
well you see no matter the aside from
them that's exactly how you just said
about your manly yeah once you see that
the girl had you know when the girl
comes up here since I'm cinnamon do you
want a lap dance no I assure you [ __ ]
pig you know you grab their tits that
put you have no respect mm-hmm grab the
tit that [ __ ] until they go stop and
you like [ __ ] you I just gave you $25
for [ __ ] about three-minute terrible
song I'm gonna try to grab this [ __ ]
then once you stop that you start
talking to them if they're real I don't
like my real name is Jesse yes it's not
cinnamon now Jesse's such a common name
and I have two kids
Jesse and Jennifer's they're all [ __ ]
never be more [ __ ] named Jennifer and
all your [ __ ] life phone number I
grew up with Irish girls you mean a
Jennifer you and you're sucking at it
sort of Buzzi so it's like once you sit
and talk to him they don't my name is
Jesse and my husband left me and I have
two kids
to light that with that mother if
they're being honest with you you know
in their voice
yeah and now they become a woman Thea
now she there's nothing different
between her and your mom
they're just trying to make ends meet
she's drawn up and she's got no
education you know maybe she does but
she knows if she goes to an office she
can't take care of a baby exacts isn't
the fastest way from A to Z and the
Frasure window for sure why she still
got a body left yeah plus he's still
tight I'll let you finger me with gloves
on you know I'm saying cuz I wanna have
two more kids after this I don't want to
have [ __ ] what's that psoriasis and my
dead skin fingers I mean I used to date
a stripper one day she came over she's
like you're not gonna believe this she
was a truck driver wanted to eat my ass
for 60 hours at that time I was broken
for 16 hours did you do it she goes you
know not really cuz I didn't want coffee
breath in my [ __ ] I know what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you goes all
truckers drink too much coffee they have
to stay up in mind so their breath is
like coffee next time what you're done
take the truck Oh button your ass
it's your [ __ ] and it's really weird
I dated a stripper and dating them is
completely different
no yes statement now you're putting
yourself on Front Street with them and
you're trying to be cool but you ain't
cool yeah you're laying on guys you're
coming home and then you start making a
little remarks gonna take a shower yeah
that's [ __ ] oh they hate that she may
hate that [ __ ] so I dated one and that
was it I knew once that was over there
was no reason for me to walk like I
didn't even hang out it's true I met her
at a comedy club in Michigan and then
she made me drive her home and then take
it uh what's the one with this 99 not
good-looking ones and one ugly one of
the fat one DejaVu DejaVu yeah oh you're
talking oh geez [ __ ] that's oh did they
staged a booze line was my land pretty
ones on one ugly yeah hey I'll do one on
purpose
do you have know some guys like we got
like three ugly ones right now and these
were the best ones yeah well they did
they did they they don't have any limits
they imagine just getting jacked off
within a minute someone who's mad
dogging you nuts
just staring him in the eye yeah we got
this one and my work right now dog oh
she's so find a DJ quit she's not fine
but you can tell she knows how to [ __ ]
and one of the DJ's quit came back a
week later got a drunk strapped her down
to his truck took her home and he was
like dog when I turn the lights on I
sobered up but when those lights were
off I was having the time of my life say
damn yeah some of those medium strippers
they haven't [ __ ] on his suckers they
were [ __ ] 4th grade for reals
it's crazy look I met a girl by the a
year ago we just talked him I don't know
what study what Columbus Utah I think it
was Utah we're talking about to the show
there was a couple people that she told
me write out why she goes you don't
understand I started giving [ __ ] in
high school yeah I don't being a soccer
wife's to blow my boyfriend everywhere
that was the big thing you look like
2:00 a.m. yeah somebody's Fisher's in
front of a lot of the people there's a
lot of the people yeah but you never
[ __ ] know you never know what these
women have run up to I like that you
work at a strip club I like that you
found that you look after them yeah
exactly look at the menu like they could
be my daughter yeah any one of them
could be my daughter
I see dad darf I've had to like tell
dad's a homie I would love to let you in
but I lose my job you wanted my advice
call her way for her and give her a
thousand this chick ain't gonna leave
this she's making a thousand today you
better give her a thousand time to meet
you outside and talk to him there's been
dad's that come in there dog really I'm
like she's she's 23 sorry dog like I'm
not well I can't do anything trying to
fight me and [ __ ] you know we had
Chelsea skidmore in here and she was
saying that she danced for a while that
her father found out and sent her a text
Wow broke my artist in the [ __ ] I would
die you know yeah but you have to look
at it who knows why people do the things
they do the evil men do George Perez
mm-hmm you got no dates in man nothing
in me me neither
Howard let's do some let's do like a 10
seater first eight people that come to
people on standby poor you and we'll
figure some money we'll do some ice
house it's high just to warm me up
before or a belly room or something what
is it what am i doing New Orleans and
Atlanta the 8th and 9th of June so we'll
do something if you got any openings in
Atlanta dog I'll paint my feeling alone
I got a redo I got my boy because I came
up from Florida from the ship Steve oh
yeah you're rescheduling everything yeah
do everything so [ __ ] kill me but I'm
happy you to contain out all day you're
tremendous on your mama's house you do
tremendous today and I'm proud thank you
thank you I learned a lot from you
dangerous mob Danger Danger Danger
I want to thank George Perez I want to
thank the flying Jew and I want to thank
you guys for listening and now for a
word from our sponsors all right you
dirty bastards I want to thank George
Perez I want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank new
little [ __ ] savages but let's give a
word out to our sponsors to get this
party started like I told you in the
beginning listen next weekend is
Mother's Day May 12th do not forget
write it down seriously where would you
be without your mom ProFlowers is here
to help you show appreciation this year
if I had a mom I'd be sending the 20 of
these you understand me as far as my
wife is concerned I will kiss her feet
on Mother's Day
when these roses coming nice beautiful
colors and they get delivered ProFlowers
let you use from a variety of bouquets
and visors that suit every mom's style
all you got to do is pick the delivery
date it's that easy then ProFlowers
carefully packages your flowers and
delivers them with fresh from the farm
to your mom who's better than them
express delivery means her flowers stay
fresh so right now you get one dozen
assorted roses for 1999 beautiful double
roses and you get a premium vaz for 9.99
more visit proflowers.com
click the microphone in the upper right
hand corner
and then the promo code happening that's
proflowers.com click the microphone on
the right hand corner and use the promo
code happening h AP pn e ing
Mother's Day is not May 12th so do not
wait order like a pro and get this
amazing Rose deal to thank all the moms
in your life the church is also brought
to you by on it listen for years from
the hot alpha brain which is 100%
money-back guarantee to the shrewd text
to the shroom tech immune sport the
protein powders on is the way to go do
me a favor go to honey calm right now
you see a supplement you like on the way
out press in church and get 10% off your
order delivered right to your house you
understand me also you want to make
month a little devious for Mother's Day
my bookie is here to help you out
whether it's pro baseball hockey MMA UFC
you got a big fight coming in Bellator
in June and you want to be ready Jack
because the bottom line is beat us you
understand me
my bookie is the place for you my bookie
loves baseball hockey and then they
constantly delivers a great selection of
bets for everything that you in your
world even better they process all
payout requests within 48 hours so you
get paid fast when you win fast Bradish
you pay you when you get paid best of
all they're easy to use mobile site lets
you place bets within seconds from
anywhere and to make sure you got plenty
of cash my bookie will give you a 50%
bonus on your first deposit just visit
my bookie AG today and use promo code
Church that's promo code Church things
are simple with my bookie you play you
win and you get paid again I want to
thank ProFlowers I want to thank my
bookie and I want to thank on it but
most importantly I want to thank you
mother [ __ ] savages while I'm here in
New York in between two [ __ ] movies
and whatnot writing and doing it all you
guys got my back always you understand
me so my name's George Perez I want
thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] have a great weekend
see you Monday morning kid top Magoo
ready to [ __ ] go George Perez Lee
take this [ __ ] meal